People tell me I’m slow.
Yeah well, you’re slow.
Everybody’s slow.
We’re all slow.
Yaaaaay!
If you’ve ever raced a cheetah and you’re
not named Usain Bolt, you probably lost.
Or heck if you even tried racing against your
cat, I bet you still lost.
From horses, to dogs, to birds, it seems the
entire animal kingdom is faster and stronger
than we are.
Why?
Well we evolved to fit into our own ecological
niche.
But even compared to our nearest relatives,
the chimpanzee and bonobos, we are considerably
weaker.
We weren’t always this way.
According to Dan Lieberman, a biological anthropologist
at Harvard University, our “chimp-like ancestor
was like a power athlete that was much stronger
and faster than humans, but they had no endurance."
But we traded our brawn for bigger brains
and the ability to outrun our prey in a long
distance hunt.
When our ancestors evolved from being mostly
tree dwellers to savannah walkers, they probably
traded strength and speed for endurance.
This is creatively called the endurance hypothesis.
Some researchers believe that humans evolved
a unique predatory style.
Rather than a fast and furious chase, like
a cheetah or Vin Diesel, humans take the slow
and steady, wear-down-your-prey-till-it-collapses-from-exhaustion
kind of action.
And this takes very specific types of muscles.
By comparison, cheetahs have muscles that
are tailored to reacting quickly so they can
reach top speed of around 70 miles per hour.
But the tradeoff is they get exhausted quickly,
they have no endurance.
While we can never run that fast, we can run
for a long time, maybe longer than any other
animal.
Sure less exciting than a high speed chase,
but incredibly effective.
But you’re also slow because you’re weak!
Don’t feel bad, we all are, comparatively
speaking.
One of our closest relatives, the chimpanzee
is about twice as strong as a human.
Because they’re arboreal and spend most
of their time in trees, most of their strength
is concentrated in their arms.
Our ancestors probably had similar muscle
strength to a chimpanzee around six million
years ago according to a study published in
PLOS One.
The researchers found that in the few million
years since, human beings evolved dramatically.
Our brains got bigger, specifically in our
prefrontal cortex, the part that deals with
long term goal planning.
They found that the prefrontal cortex was
RADICALLY different in humans from that in
chimpanzees, monkeys, and mice.
It seemed to have evolved 4 times faster than
the other parts of the body.
And that’s because in part, humans started
to evolve social structures that allowed us
to, say, work together as a team to take down
bigger prey.
But there is a downside to a bigger brain.
A bigger brain consumes more energy.
Our brains consume 20% of the energy we use,
which is a lot compared to other animals.
So where did the energy come from?
Maybe from our muscles.
The researchers also found our ancestor’s
MUSCLES changed rapidly too.
Very rapidly, about 8 times faster than the
rest of our body.
So researchers believe that to deal with the
energy demands of a bigger brain, our ancestors
evolved smaller muscles to compensate.
But more research is needed.
You may think this contradicts the Darwinian
principle of “survival of the fittest,”
but “fit” in this context doesn’t mean
physical fitness.
It means an organism fits in a niche long
enough to reproduce, so the genetic lineage
survives.
And it’s not that being a smart wimp is
always better than being a big dumb ox or
vice versa, it’s a matter of what’s most
beneficial for an organism based on its environment
and competition.
If coming down from the trees and learning
to make fire means one day your offspring
will populate the globe, it’s probably worth
giving up looking like a species of Mr. Universes.
That’s evolution.
CTA video
So you can’t outrun a cheetah but you can
definitely out-walk it.
Julia covers the endurance hypothesis in more
detail here.
If you had the option to be ripped but also
couldn’t form basic sentences, would you
take it?
Mash your keyboard in the comments, subscribe
for more, and I’ll see you next time on
DNews.